[Music]
if you haven't heard there is a problem
for the millennials
george dave i've lost the millennial
weight loss program
the there's an avocado ban
on avocados coming in from mexico so
it's a healthy fat
i know but the
i'm just saying millennial
avocado toast is
uh toast
uh un until we get our avocados back and
so well oh wait
it's been reversed that was friday they
on friday they lifted the ban
you're gonna make it george
you're gonna make it this is the best
news i've read in a long time because i
mean you had lost like a half a pound i
know he's getting dangerous you didn't
have a half a pound to lose no
so this is wild so mexico supplies about
80 percent of the avocados eat in the
united states there was a ban
and it's been lifted and it's stemming
from purported threats to a u.s
inspector
in the latin american
country shook a bill so the cartel got
after a u.s inspector hanging out down
there gave him a little one-up and he uh
he shuts down a billion dollars worth of
avocado toast buddy i'm just saying this
is this guy's this guy's got power i'm
in the wrong industry what's your son do
he's an avocado inspector but he
actually runs the entire economy of
mexico
a billion dollars worth of avocados
so uh yeah of course during the ban you
thought getting out of debt was the mean
tweet the mean tweets thing is coming
back during the ban
kimberly and i won't read your last name
because i don't want people to come
after that's not the spirit here she
might be 12 you never know
um she might be 82 and in either case
would we want people to
you know like bother kimberly that's
right she says i bet you dave ramsey is
super stoked about the avocado import
band he's like these millennials can't
waste their millions on avocado toast
anymore there you go see i knew it was
coming i don't know how i got hooked up
with that because i don't remember me
saying that one i don't think you better
there's another financial guy out there
in the space and i can't i think it
might have been david bach i don't
remember but we've always used
examples that say okay if you cut your
spending
by just a little bit and invest that you
will end up with money we've said that
long before millennials were born we
said that
and one example was always you know if
you cut out a cup of coffee if you quit
buying coffee and then it became
starbucks five bucks right now it's with
inflation's eight bucks but um
and then with a latte it's 26 bucks
insane and with universal um
life wage of 42 an hour it's now 42. and
if you uber it and have it brought in by
uber eats with the up charges it's 62
dollars this is getting out so yeah i'm
just saying but anyway
a cup of coffee you know if you just
said i'm not going to spend that instead
i'm going to let that money accumulate
into an investment turns into money it's
a math example it's not an actual
suggestion that says you become wealthy
by not drinking coffee or not eating
that's how millennials took it but
somebody said
the millennials were you know back when
we first started everybody started
griping about millennials the millennial
hate thing started right like they're
they're useless they get participation
trophies they live in their mother's
basement you know all that stuff that
was said about millennials which is not
true by the way but it was a and and
some some body in the financial world it
really wasn't me i don't think if you
can find the tweet out there send it to
me if i did it i'll own it because i've
said some stupid butt stuff but do you
think i said it james no i think it just
was a meme going around that no somebody
picked it up off of me there was
actually a guy said it i'm positive and
then it turned into a meme and then it
turned into i said i got conflated with
you yeah i i said that's how i tell
people to live on less than they make i
tell them not to do foolish spending and
this guy's point was the millennials
would be okay if they could spend their
money on avocado toast and put their
money in a roth ira and that's you know
absolutely not true that doesn't work
mathematically but it's an example it's
a metaphor for control your spending but
uh but then the millennials get all
jacked up and entitled they're like well
they might have a kind of toast you know
well now they buy it to spite you that's
what they do well i i actually like it
people are hate buying i never had
avocado toast until this whole thing got
pinned on me it's delicious and i
actually order it now so but i can
afford it so new headline dave ramsey
orders avocado toast that's that's
shocking that's it can you cover it with
gravy that's what i want to know but
yeah okay
[Laughter]
red eye gravy baby all right uh so i bet
you dave ramsey's super stoked about the
avocado import ban he's like ha ha
these millennials can't waste their
millions on avocado toast anymore wow so
that's again that's the whole story me
getting pinned with this thing um i love
the assumption that these millennials
have millions that they're just i guess
collectively
collectively they're spending millions
maybe yeah
but we do love our avocados don't take
those away so here's the thing
the mean tweets we used to have to kind
of when twitter was young
it was actually a conversation
now it's just a bunch of trolls it's
just it's deteriorated it's just a
you know it's a paw trolls it's a troll
pile and so but the uh um so finding
mean tweets in the old days it was one
out of
500 tweets or something but you could do
a majority do a search on dave ramsey
you could find me in tweets all you got
to do is open up now it's not hard at
all
boomer you know you get anything or
every possible name that you can call
people uh yeah so james we if we're
gonna do mean tweets they cannot we we
can't violate the fcc rules on word said
on the air so we can't use a lot of them
we'll just have to bleep them we can
bleep them and they have to be creative
and funny and fun not just like oh man
i'm not just hateful not just angry
basically he wants you to be creatively
mean if you're going to be mean do it if
you want to make a show with your mean
tweet
you need to be
mean without unbelievable cuss words
because we can't use them that's true
we're actually on public radio we'll get
fined the funniest ones were from the
kids in class that were taking they were
they were forced to go through the
curriculum yeah they're in you know
because 48 of the classes are teaching
our curriculum in high schools now 48 of
high schools are teaching it so you know
they're making fun of dave ramsey i'm
going to watch these videos the coach i
wish the coach should actually do his
job and teach and now he's a coach he's
not a teacher yeah and now you've passed
it on to me i hosted our latest
curriculum so now i get the haters you
get you can hate me i have kids saying
this guy's a tool really yeah
i i guess i don't know i don't even know
what a tool is
huh but hey it's an avocado tool avocado
tool i'll take that but the kids these
days are called toast eating they think
they're just
posting into the abyss they don't know
that we can see it especially when they
direct message you right that's a whole
different ball game well here's the
thing the problem yeah it's just the
problem with this i think i think we're
going to see a change in this i think
it's in the air
because it's gotten so far out of
control
um
and the problem with this is that and we
kept trying to tell people this in the
early days with social media when it
first started especially twitter
and it's going to come back to bite you
because this stuff is forever
even if you delete the tweet somebody
could have screenshotted it oh yeah even
if you delete the instagram comment
somebody could have screenshotted it
and so um
i'm up to like i think i've blocked ten
thousand people that's impressive
it was a hobby for a while yeah you
gotta i would kind of drink my morning
coffee i block ten a morning you know
that's good and it's like pace yourself
well if you're gonna cuss me and you
know all those other stuff you know but
uh well now it's a it's a medal of honor
i don't know if you know that but people
are excited to get blocked by you and
they hold it up as a badge really it's a
thing they brag about it to their
friends
oh man it's a real thing who knew i
could create a different kind of um
it's the only competition they can win
so they like to hold that up
sorry was that too i'm sorry i take it
back that was good take it back zing
it's a sport this is a trophy you
actually earned
a block by dave trophy
it's you can't mount it on the wall but
it's great dinner time conversation
wow well i mean
moms and dads um that raise kids that
say things on the internet that they
would never have the
backbone to say in person
because you get your face punched in if
you said this to someone's face yeah you
know and so you know it's and i watch
them you know they're talking about some
quarterback or
some vaccinated thing on some
quarterback or whatever they're wearing
out aaron rodgers they're wearing out
whoever
and you know
as
if you stood in that guy's presence he's
the size of it not aaron rodgers but i
mean you know sure he'd have one of his
linemen pound you into the ground like
avocado toast i mean there it is we got
a full circle we came back around all
right main tweets coming up not this
segment but soon james is going to try
to collect ones that are actually funny
james might write some be careful
james be careful he could get the booth
people don't get him
the booth
to get back at me for calling them both
folks
is coming the comeuppance no idea what's
coming on the internet now
this is the ramsey show